that's something very special about
Barcelona like any time you go out of
your house there's always something
going on you'll always find a friend on
the streets
it's where living is you're not in your
place you're on the street
yeah that you can go out in the street
at night and it's always lively it's
never nobody in the Ramblas for example
they're always every hour a day there's
life I came here I felt somehow better
than in Amsterdam or more alive more
fatale understand vital that's yeah that
makes it very enjoyable at least for me
inspiring too
it's very nice place because and in the
Rambla you come you can find Aaron Oh
theater music from Argentina from Spain
from Africa for all the world
things that on the street happen never
will happen in a theater for example if
we play in like 1015 people start to
dance at one time for example then you
think like yeah this is this is
beautiful you know the Ramblas is this
street in Barcelona
and I think in Europe and maybe in the
world that like you're going to be
entertained no matter how I mean if you
walk past by the flower shops I mean the
way they build it up is beautiful even
the street is decorated I mean you get
entertained it's worth coming to
Barcelona
it's a way of life downloads is you have
everything you have traffic of people
you have to dish your piece your
performers Ramos is everything it's it's
it's a vibrant of life
yeah it's a way of life truly really a
way of life I love it
hi